we believe that the moment after the
child is outside of the birth canal that
they are now endowed with human rights
yes however when they are inside of the
mother literally anything you do to them
is acceptable because they're inside of
the mother oh no I don't think anything
is acceptable but I think the mother
should still have the choice ultimate uh
authority over what happens to her body
but there's a child inside what about
meth
uh uh like should she be allowed to do
meth yeah
uh I think if someone is doing meth
while they're pregnant that it is
completely acceptable for something like
uh
I don't know what the name of the
services in the United States Child
Services would be yeah it's our body
though
yeah it's her body she wants to do math
what's the big deal
uh the big deal is that it's she's
intentionally trying to kill a child
hold on there a minute yeah and I see
where we're going I don't I don't
understand what you're saying it's her
body it's her body wants to do meth
what's the problem
well first off doing meth is a legal
period